have you John sheikha the University of
Utah will be talking about his first off
thanks to the organizers for inviting me
and organizing such a great conference
with so many great talks so I'm going to
be talking today about interval exchange
transformations and flows on flat
surfaces subject I like a lot and in
particular I'm going to be going to be
talking about the isomorphism problem
and another thing called disjoint nuh
switch i'll introduce and so the basic
idea is typically does it happen that
for some strange reason most I ETS are
actually all the same so before going
into interval exchange transformations
let's start with rotations of the circle
so let's just think about the unit
circle in the complex plane and think of
a very simple isometry on it you just
take it in rigidly rotate it by an alpha
the proportion of its circumference so
that's the map that's given there and I
used to guess i'm assuming access
between 0 and 1 and so it's just rigidly
rotating by an alphas proportion of its
circumference we can instead of thinking
about this in the you you could just
think about X and forget about the e to
the 2 pi and this is very similar to
just a map of the 01 interval to itself
given by shifting everything over by
alpha well then you might leave the 01
interval so just subtract off the
integer part so this is just X plus
alpha modulo 1 so this is one of the
first introduced in best understood
dynamical systems and it shows up in a
variety of ways I'll mention one of them
so you can also take the square Taurus
and hit it by this particular element 1
alpha 0 1 you get some other tours with
a nice flat metric on it and opposite
sides are identified and so you can just
consider flown straight up on this so we
just flows straight upwards and sorry
and so you get that you reach the top
and then you move over back to the
bottom and then you
at the side and you move back over to
the top and repeat and so this is a map
of the tourists on the tourists it's a
flow on the torus but maybe you're like
me and two dimensions is much too hard
and you prefer one dimension one
dimension something nice and so since
I'm just flowing by a straight line flow
till I get to the top and I don't have
any other identifications maybe I just
want to think about what this is doing
on the bottom where this blue line that
starts at some place on the bottom next
crosses the bottom and that gives me
some dynamical system just on the bottom
this is called the first return map for
obvious reasons which are that you start
on a point in a set and then you just
map it to where it first returns to that
set okay and so if you look at that
that's going to give you rotation by
minus alpha okay where the Alpha here
the same as the Alpha on top so this is
a way that rotations show up so
rotations have to kind of basic
different types there's rational
rotations in irrational rotations
rational rotations each point has only
finitely many points in its orbit then
it comes back to where it started and
repeats it the number of things in the
denominator when it's written in lease
terms and otherwise your irrational and
it turns out that if your irrational the
orbit of every point will be dense and
even more it distributes the right
amount in any interval so if you ask how
many times it asymptotically lands in
the interval from zero to one half it's
half of the time and there's nothing
special about the interval from zero to
one half it's for any interval it hits
it as often as it should which is the
length and so this is called unique or
go to city in an hour context this is
equivalent to the fact that if you want
special measures which are probability
measures in which when you push them
forward under the dynamics you get back
the same measure you taught us started
with these are called preserved measures
because pushing them forward keeps them
the same then there's only one of these
we want such probability measure and in
this case it's lebesgue measure okay and
so in ergodic theory you usually have
descriptions of almost every orbits with
respect to any ergodic measures you have
but unique or
city in our context is wonderful because
you get descriptions of every single
orbit and this is a very special thing
very nice thing so we know how every
point travels through the space at least
coarsely as in how many times it'll take
a given interval okay so any questions
on this okay so now we can talk about
the isomorphism problem and so what does
the isomorphism problem ask so we're
given to dynamical systems T X mu and sy
new team apps the space X to itself and
s Maps the space Y to itself t preserves
mu and s preserves in new and the
question is when are they actually the
same so what is the same mean so if
they're the same it means that you have
um we have X and X here and we have Y
and Y here and I'm moving across by X IT
you're removing across by Y by ass and
what when they're the same it means that
if I fur that I have a map Phi that
makes this thing commute and it also has
an inverse that also makes it commute
and push mower pushes forward to measure
mewtwo new and pushes forward the
measure new tomb you so I think a
picture is much more helpful than the
definition which is written up there so
the point is if I should be by jective
by measure preserving and push forward
move to new and therefore it also pushes
new from you because it's by detective
and this is in measure category so we
only care about things almost everywhere
I don't care if on a set of measure zero
but in this setting of rotations
everything is super nice and so it turns
out that the isomorphism problem has
completely solved for irrational
rotations we're wondering when two
rotations are isomorphic and this
problem is completely solved it was
solved in 1942 by how mohsin von Neumann
and so it's only in the obvious case
there's no secret ways that rotations
that look like they shouldn't be the
same are actually the same so you could
either be alpha some things isomorphic
to itself that's no
prize or minus alpha and it's not hard
to see that conjugating x minus the
identity is the isomorphism in this case
so um that's a great thing we've
completely solved the problem hey there
men just a brief remark on their methods
their spectral and it works for systems
that have discrete spectrum and it's not
hard to see that rotations have an
orthonormal basis of l2 given by
eigenfunctions so the spectrum is purely
discrete and this is a private enabled
them to get a classification of when two
systems with discrete spectrum are well
conjugate but in our setting isomorphic
right so and in particular so you have a
map of the spaces 012 itself and it
preserves lebesgue measure so it acts as
an isometry on l2 of lambda of the unit
interval now it turns out it's
invertible so it's actually unitary and
you can look at the spectrum and in our
case it's discrete speck of pure point
spectrum and that's how they come up
with your classification so any
questions on rotations or anything like
that because I'm about to move on to IET
s okay so here's the definition of an
ayiti what do you do you take the you
take an interval and you chop it up into
deep pieces of different lengths so the
length star l1 out to LD and you know
the third interval starts with a second
interval ended so that's the idea behind
this and then you exchange them
according to an order so your point lies
in some interval you subtract off the
intervals that started before it and you
move in all of the intervals that are
sent before it by a permutation okay so
that's the definition and as is often
the case a picture is worth at least a
thousand words so I'm drawing you a
picture of an interval exchange
transformation the colors tell is so I'm
chopping the interval I care about into
three pieces blue red and black and I'll
exchange them according to the order
three goes first thence comes second and
then comes first so that's the order I'm
doing
and so let's see what happens okay so
the black piece gets sent to the
beginning the blue piece gets sent to
the end and the red base gets shifted
over by the difference in lengths
between the third and first interval
it's not hard to see that from this that
you would if you were effects was in the
second interval you would subtract off
the first interval the only thing less
than two is one and then you'd add to it
will sent before it the three so because
to get sent to 23 get sent to one and
when you cut again this is a dynamical
system we cut according to the same rule
we previously had so we cut into the
same places and things get split up even
more okay so um the end of red in all of
blue gets sent to the beginning right
because that's underneath where black
was at the beginning so that's an
interval exchange transformation and
let's say a few words about them these
are nice systems so first off they
generalize rotations why did I start
talking about rotations because they are
the simplest interval exchange
transformation they're interval exchange
transformations of two intervals and so
their lengths are so I need to tell you
the permutation well that's not very
hard if it was 12 it would be the
identity so it's two goes to one and the
lengths are 1 minus alpha and alpha so
the any piece gets pushed over by alpha
goes to the it goes to the interval from
1 to 2 you subtract one off because
you're really doing everything bad one
and it gets sent to the beginning the
part from 0 to 1 minus alpha gets
shifted over by alpha and stays in the
interval and that's how to say that
rotations are too i 80s so rotations are
ordered preserving I sama trees that
preserve lebesgue measure not really
nice systems similarly interval exchange
transformations are piecewise isometries
they might actually be discontinuous
it's not hard to see that this picture
we saw above actually is discontinuous
and they're piecewise I sama trees
they're piecewise or order preserving
and they're invertible
so in widens talk some things that were
piecewise isometries but weren't
invertible came up but these are
invertible and that means that they
preserve lebesgue measure and there in
verse is always also in interval
exchange transformation so these are
nice things they have a lot of nice
properties so um so you can fix in order
on the interval exchange transformation
and then it only is determined by the
lengths by the by the length by the
length vector okay so in the case we saw
before this would be the length of red
the length of blue and the length of
black that determines the entire
dynamics and you might as well assume
that the sum of all of the lengths is
equal to 1 because you can always
normalize to make this the case by just
dividing by the total lengths sum of all
of the intervals and that doesn't really
change the dynamics so we identify
interval exchange transformations with a
fixed order on with the simplex of
dimension one less than than the number
of the letters sitting in art of the day
okay so the standard simplex because we
want all of our length vectors to be
non-negative right we shouldn't have
negative length and we're having a
one-dimensional condition that the sum
of things add up to one so it's
dimension D minus 1 so what's the
important thing about this this is now a
nice Euclidean space it has a uniform
measure on it it has a metric you can
say words like almost every point in it
and so when we talk about almost every
IET what we think of there's a fixed
order and then you identify the I ETS
with that as the simplex that's the
parameterizing space and then almost
every is almost every point in that
parameterizing space which with with
respect to the natural d minus one
dimensional volume in so there's a great
theorem about an interval exchange
transformations by Mazur & Veatch which
is some analog of wiles theorem and what
is it it's that almost every interval
exchange transformation is uniquely
ergodic with respect to lebesgue measure
okay so we have exactly what we had in
Wireless theorem that for almost every
rotation any point falls in an interval
as often as it should
proportional to the length of that over
the total length of the space unlike
wiles theorem we don't have a full
classification but that might be a
little bit too much to ask these are not
as nice as rotations they're still very
nice not as nice so yeah and also the
only preserved measure is labaik just as
in the other case I should remark that
in the case of rotations ue had a
dichotomy either the orbit of every
point was periodic or the orbit of every
point was uniformly distributed and you
had unique or get a city that the
economy fails for interval exchange
transformations but that's a subject for
different talks okay so we talked about
how rotations came about from flows on
tour I in the same way interval exchange
transformations come about from flows on
something else they come about from
flows on dream on surfaces with some
special metric and what is this special
metric there's a finite number of bad
points um that aren't so bad and away
from that boy those bad points the
transition functions between charts have
to be translations okay and I told you
that the bad points shouldn't be so bad
there except they're cone angles of
integer multiples of 2pi ok so I think a
picture is often worth us a thousand
words and this is definitely the case
here what we have here is we have a flat
surface and opposite sides are
identified so I've drawn you the chart
and the transition functions so if I
cross from here to here I come back here
if I come here and ahead here I come
back over here come down so forth does
the picture make sense opposite sides
are identified and that's the transition
tells you the transition functions
between the charts um so I mention this
thing about bad points if you look at
this this point here has to be the same
as this point here because their end
points of the same side and similarly it
has to be the same point as here and if
you look all of the corners actually
have to be the same point and you can do
an angle calculor
just go around here start counting the
angles then come up here and keep
counting the angle and repeat this and
keep counting the angle and you'll get
that it's six pi okay so that's the
exceptional point which has angle and
integer multiple of 2 pi so this is a
genus to surface with one singularity of
65 so the charts are translations and so
they preserve orientation and they
preserve angles so you can lift straight
lines from the plane to your to your
flat surface and it makes sense to keep
going unless you land in one of these
cone points where then it's unclear
which way you should shoot out you have
several choices of shooting out if you
do that and so there is a well-defined
flow in each direction on the flat
surface except at a measure zero set of
points these ones that land and that go
from one singulair that lay that hit a
singularity in either direction okay and
you get this in every direction right so
I these flows give us an i 80 and i
think i will do a proof by showing you
pictures so what can i do i can start
with the bottom and i just flow up and
in this special example part of the
bottom goes all the way up to the top
where will be identified right back to
the bottom so we're playing the same
game we did on the taurus we're fix in
one side we're doing a flow in this case
also in the vertical direction and
sending points on the bottom to where
they next cross the bottom does that
make sense and in particular since the
bottom and the top are identified it's
also where they cross the top okay so
we've got this point on the bottom is a
segment on the bottom and it flows all
the way up and it identifies to the top
there now it can't be extended any
further because it'll hit this cone
point right which will have some
different identification and send it
somewhere else so what you're seeing
already is on the segment that up until
a certain point it everything's moving
by Osama trees that are preserving order
right and at cone points other things
happen but on these segments things are
moving by or to preserving isometries
let's look at the next piece so this is
colored in blue it will be split into
two different part
a little bit but let's first follow it
so it flows up and hits the angled side
up top and then and then it gets
identified back to the bottom now it
flows up close up and eats up most of
that side notice the little part that's
black on the bottom will fill in the
rest of that side and then we follow the
identification and goes over to the
other side now it flows up and part of
it will go all the way up to the top
which will then be identified in the
bottom and part of it will hit this
corner area here and those will be
covered colored in yellow and green so
now the yellow part has been identified
back to the top the green part hasn't it
hits there it goes over and then comes
all the way to the end so the back of
blue gets sent to the very front of the
interval we started with and so just
take my word for it this last black
piece comes up over and gets I over hits
here comes here and fills in that last
little piece there so that's seeing that
the vertical flow is giving us an
interval exchange transformation and
everything is I saw in through the
identification is in order preserving
isometry at least piecewise so um that's
the picture and so just to wrap this up
so here's an interval exchange
transformation we see so the first
interval gets sent to the second
position the second pin but the second
interval get set to the last position
the third interval get sent to the first
position and the fourth interval gets
sent to the third position and so
there's also and so there's also a space
of these guys I could have varied my
angles between the sides right I could
have taken these and I could have moved
it a little bit or i could have
stretched and shrink the length of
things still keeping parallel sides
parallel in of the same length so things
are moved in pairs okay and I could get
a whole local neighborhood of interval
of flat surfaces
and so this gives us local coordinates
on the space and so it makes sense to
talk about almost every flat surface as
well and so a serene beach also proved
that independently that for almost every
flat surface the vertical flow is
uniquely ergodic so we have the same
statement about pushing forward of a
single measure to get back itself single
probability measure or alternately you
can do the version of intervals rather
than hitting an interval we're looking
at time spent in a rectangle and you hit
the right amount so I'm not assuming
these are unit area so I want to
normalize by the volume of the surface
by the area of the surface so that's a
flood that so the typical those typical
things are uniquely organic as well so
now we want to consider the isomorphism
problem for interval exchange
transformations and so almost every pair
of interval exchange transformations are
not isomorphic similarly to the case of
maser invitas theorem generalizing while
theorem there's no longer this kind of
generalizes the how most by norman
theorem and we also lose a complete
classification but that's somehow I
think maybe asking a bit much and
moreover they are disjoint something
i'll define in a moment and jointly with
vibe of god ray i prove we prove that
the same thing is true for vertical
flows on almost every flat surface so if
i take one flat surface and i take
another flat surface and look at the
vertical flows on both of them chances
are they're actually different there's
no measurable map that secretly sends
one to the other and so that the
dynamics commute so i should tell you
what this word destroy means it's a
notion of difference and so what is it
you want to take to measure preserving
transformations and you want to consider
the product transformation so our space
was x and y 2 separate spaces but
instead we consider the space X cross Y
and on the first coordinate we move by T
and on the second coordinate we removed
by us and then we want to look at the
systems we see in here
so that's identified by measures that
are preserved those are the systems but
we want them to somehow have something
to do with t and s so we want them to
project to the first coordinate as mu
into the second coordinate as you do so
that's the idea of adjoining between the
measures and your dish you always have
launched such map so you always have one
such measure and that's the product
measure product measure always is a
preserved measure and they're disjoint
if that's the only one and so a way to
study how systems are interacting is by
studying these measures which are called
joinings and so the product measure is
called the trivial joiner okay so i
should convince you now that this is a
notion of two things being different I
said moreover right so in particular is
this should imply that they're not
isomorphic so I want to convince you
about that okay so we have a so I want
to tell you a space is not destroyed
from itself so the diagonal supports a
perfectly good joining right and so it's
not hard to see that you can move you
can look at the day you can look at X
comma Phi of X and if T and ass are
isomorphic this will be some kind of a
diagonal type thing which will also
support a joining of the two so they
can't possibly be disjoint that makes
sense so in particular plies not
isomorphic but I said moreover so I
should tell you it's more than that okay
so you can also ask about factors so
what's a factor so let's say I drop the
condition that this is invertible and I
just want this diagram to commute then
and push forward mewtwo being new that's
saying that s is a factor of T and the
thigh is like the fact or map it's a
kind of simpler thing you forget you're
possibly forgetting some data with thigh
and seeing what's left is just ass does
that make sense what a factor is yeah
and you want this diagram
and so if you have a factor that
supports are joining too so you can look
at where you get sent by the factor map
and then pull back everything that gets
sent there now T makes it so that when
you apply to this it goes to T of X H
inverse h TX because the diagram
commutes and so the so the factor will
support adjoining that's called a kind
of also like a bigger diagonal type
thing that should be a Phi sorry about
that H is Phi sorry it is fine and so if
two transformations have a non-trivial
common factor you can just pull back the
factor map on both of them and get
adjoining between them so sharing a so
two things being disjoint implies that
they have no common factors so they're
really different they don't even have
pieces that look the same okay and just
to remark that this is a different thing
than in the case of rotations was this
problem is also completely classified
because it's very possible for two
rotations to be not isomorphic but still
not disjoint so in particular if you
look at rotation by beta and by rotation
by two beta 1 is a factor of the other
so you can consider the map times so
let's do an example here this will be
rotation by beta this will be rotation
by two beta in the map I want to
consider is the times to map so what is
this times to map so times to map of X
is going to be 2 X mod 1 or minus the
integer part of 2x okay and so the
distributive property says that the time
that rotation by two beta is a factor of
rotation by beta by this map okay and
clearly this they're not isomorphic but
all right so there's some consequences
of this result so for almost every pair
of interval exchange transformations T&S
the product is uniquely ergodic with
respect to lambda
with respect to the product of lebesgue
measure so why is that because when you
project what your measure projects you
better be a preserved measure of T&S and
for the typical IET there's only one
choice by maser & Veatch and that's
lebesgue measure now if you project to
the right thing being disjoint means
there's only one choice of that and
that's the product of the two so that's
the only possibility so this is some
kind of version of measure of each
theorem for the product of two interval
exchange transformations and I should
remark that there's nothing special
about to you can the product of two
district of two interval exchange
transformation is disjoint from almost
every interval exchange transformation
so the same thing is true for three
tuples or kate apples now if you think
about what it still you if you think
about what a product of two interval
exchange transformations is you cut the
interval on one of the sides and you cut
the interval on the other sides and then
you exchange things so a box that you're
left with will be sent somewhere so this
gives us an example of rectangle
exchange transformations and
unfortunately unlike interval exchange
transformations which you can cut any
way you want and so long as you fix your
order you you can send them and that's a
well-defined map it's not clear you can
do this for rectangle exchanges but you
can when they're the product of two IEDs
right that's those always give us
rectangle exchanges and so what we get
is that the orbit of almost every point
is recurrent and so what does it mean to
be a recurrent it means that under your
dynamics you come back arbitrarily close
to yourself so your distance under it at
least along a subsequence is tending
towards zero along a subsequence then
why is this because you're uniquely
organic so you hit every region as often
as you should so if I fix a small ball
about a point this has some paths mall
but positive measure so I have to hit it
infinitely often in fact the right
proportion of times and so there's still
an open question of Gower's which is
does every rectangle exchange have the
property that every single point is
recurrent
so I think it's known it still for
interval exchanges it has been known at
least since the 70s that every point is
recurrent and so this is asking for some
kind of two-dimensional generalization
so just a remark I think he says in an
article that he suspects the answer is
yes and that other people suspect the
answer is now so that's a question yeah
so I should remark that this is still
open even for the product of two
interval exchange transformations in a
possible place to look for a counter
example would be a pair of IEDs that
have some kind of crazy joining between
each other that might control some
orbits and some orbits might spend time
near one measure and your another
measure yeah so I just wanted to stress
that it's still open even for the
product of two I ETS um so I'm going to
now tell you a little bit about the
method of proof of the fact that two
typical interval exchange
transformations are different from each
other and so this the method of this
proof is also spectral so it relies on a
criterion for destroyed pneus due to
Frank on and bill Perry and Franklin
used to be at Yale emoji unfortunately
died very young and so so what are we
going to do we'll for simply for we're
going to consider l2 functions of
integral 0 because constant functions
get sent to themselves by measure
preserving maps so yeah and so we want
some way of saying that two things are
destroyed so this is a notion of
difference so we should have some way of
saying that two things are different and
hopefully it's a very robust mechanism
because i have uncountably many objects
that i want to somehow distinguish okay
so I'm going to use sequences to do that
where one transformation is behaving
very differently than the way the other
transformation is behaving so in
particular what I'm requesting is I'm
requesting that one of them is
converging to the identity in the strong
operator topology with a weak operator
topology well the other one is
converging to the zero operator in the
week operator topology ok so the it
shouldn't be surprising
that this is a note that these two
things better be very different than
each other these are two very different
phenomenons and this actually implies
that they're disjoint but I don't know
if everybody knows what the strong and
weak operator topology or remembers this
late hour of the Saturday so here's the
definition so what is it convergence in
the strong operator topology to the
identity means it means if I fix any
vector and I start applying the powers
to it this sequence of powers it's going
in l2 to this to itself ok so the l2
norm is going to 0 just along the
sequence subsequence so maybe i'll just
make a remark rotations are definitely
not that many rotations are not the
identity but even irrational rotations
are have powers that converge in the
strong operator topology to the identity
so this is not saying that these
transformations are the identity or
periodic or something okay and then what
does it mean to converge to the zero
operator in the week operator topology
it means if i consider an inner product
between two vectors but one of them on
pushing by my unitary map along the
subsequence then this is going to Z this
is going to 0 okay it's what is the 0
operator applied to F comma G would do
ok so any questions on that and so maybe
it helps to say these things in words
that don't use l2 stuff so it's also
saying that if you in l1 norm the
function X goes to t to the n sub I of
ax is converging to the identity
function X goes tax that's l1 norm there
while in l2 morn things are getting
spread out and mixed right this is like
independence this bottom condition that
the integral of f composed with s to the
n I times G is going to the integral of
F times the integral of J so this is
some kind of it's becoming
asymptotically independent under the
applications of s to the n I
so this what is this mean for those who
are familiar with dynamics it means
along this sequence s looks like it's
mixing and along the other sequence he
looks like it's converging to the
identity so maybe from a more dynamical
standpoint that seems like they better
be very different so how do we go about
showing that four is the typical pair of
I eighties I can find a sequence where
one is converging in the strong operator
topology to the identity where the other
is converging in the week operator
topology to the zero operator so
fortunately wieners lemma tells us that
if if I if you have continuous spectrum
then there's a sequence of density one
where your Fourier coefficients of your
spectral measure converges to 0 ok so
somehow big if you have continuous
spectrum having sequences you have lots
of sequences that converge to 0 in the
week operator topology and by work of
the villa in forney almost every
interval exchange transformation has
purely continuous spectrum aside from
constant functions so what we do is we
start out with our transformation ass
that's weekly mixing and we get a
density one sequence where it's
converging in the week operator topology
20 and so all we need to do for our
other transformation T is to find a
rigidity sequence in this sequence that
basically all of the natural numbers and
it's missing some its most of them its
density one should i define what density
one means and you wouldn't not know ok
in organism so then you need to do the
next theorem which is that in any
sequence of density won almost every
interval exchange transformation has a
rigidity sequence so just briefly the
logic of the proof is you pick almost
every interval exchange transformation
which is weakly mixing you get your
sequence of density one of time
where it's converging to zero and then
this density one sequence gives you a
full measure set of I ETS depending on
your sequence where those where each
such IET can find a sequence where
converges to the identity in the so I
should remark it was already known that
almost every interval exchange
transformation had a sequence where it
converged to the identity and this was
proved by veitch so this is a mild
strengthening of a result of each and so
I mean it's preposterous that it has to
be density one any positive density
should be more than enough I don't know
how to do this I think it's a great
question so we have another question um
which is do circles equi distribute in
every flat surface so what do I mean by
this I mean I want to start at a point
and I want to flow simultaneously in all
directions but at the same speed right
and so the question is does this akwa
distribute and I don't know about you
guys but I think the answer better it
should be yes I really do and so you
want to can play with quantifiers but I
don't know how to do this and so this is
part of work in progress with Pascal who
bear and we showed that for almost every
flat surface and for any point in that's
flat surface it's true except we can't
say that much we can't say about all
times we need to toss out a density 0
set of times so there exist some o on
the bottom this I should have a p
underneath it you have some said of the
real numbers of full density so that for
any so that along times in that you're
becoming equi distributed and so that
means you hit every rectangle as often
as you should so oh yeah ok this is
written incorrectly I'm sorry so what
did we show yeah sorry about this
so we showed the following thing we
showed that the integral from 0 to 2pi
of f of f of u flow you do flaps 5th low
so what are we doing we're flowing at
all of the different directions we could
and we're just integrating d theta we're
not integrating DT and we're taking the
limit of tea in our special set a sub P
ok and this converges to what it should
which is the integral of the function
over the measure of the space ok so
that's what we yes yes I did yeah thanks
so it suffices to check on on continuous
functions or rectangles to check for
equi distribution and so this shows that
circles akwid distribute typically but
maybe some remarks on quantifiers
unfortunately this result only holds for
a non explicit set of full measure
completely non-explicit it also only
holds for a density one set of x which
is unfortunate fortunately we get it for
every point but those are two remarks on
the fact that the quantifiers are far
from being optimal and so how do we go
about doing this so I first claim that
it suffices to show that for typical
pair n tuples of directions the flow in
those n tuples are uniquely ergodic okay
and why is this so first I should call
attention to the fact that this will let
me control all orbits and if we're
flowing a point in different directions
we're starting from the same point so
this is describing a measure 0 set in
the product of the surfaces so we really
want to control every single point ok
but why should is so it's clear we want
some kind of control on every single
point but why is this good
well so by the strong law of large
number if I take a product of my surface
with itself n times where n is some
enormous number and I pick a rectangle
for most points in the product of these
surfaces I'm no longer restricting to
the diagonal so for most points in the
product of these surfaces it's going to
hit rectangles as often as it should and
this is just the strong law of large
numbers what's happening on one surface
has nothing to do with the others these
are all independent does that make sense
ok so this is a so for fixed and this is
the set where we hit a rectangle either
much more or much less than we should is
some kind of set of very small measure
ok the Omega should be a cue sorry about
that but we are only comparing about a
measures caring about a measure 0 set of
points are P come up that p but if we're
uniquely organic we control that point
to and it akwid distributes in the
product of n copies of the flat surface
so you look at your good set which is
the complement of the set so we have our
set here which is somehow the bad set
the set that spends too much time in a
rectangle and the good set has almost
full measure so under Adam emek severy
point spends the vast majority of its
time in the good set not the bad set
because the good set has almost full
measure where the projection is all
about the same and what is this exactly
saying this is exactly a point about
flowing at time ass in the different
direction to your point P and having
them land in the rectangle as often as
they should right does that make sense
so you want to think of the product of
many surfaces and your flowing in each
of them separately but then you want to
project it back down to your original
surface and see that your cloud is
pretty well distributed it's the picture
and to prove unique organism it's of
Isis to show that for any n and it
suffices to prove disjoint pneus and
this is by an inductive argument you get
unique or get a city of the product and
then you get this joint pneus of the of
the next one from the previous one so
you get unique or get a city of now the
end couple of products in each time you
set toss out a set of zero matter but
it's only a set of zero matter and so
what we really proved is that for almost
every flat surface and any n for almost
every and couple of directions the flow
is just the flow from the first n minus
1 the product of the first n minus 1 is
destroyed from the last one and that's
what we proof and so unfortunately it's
only for almost every flat surface and I
should remark that this doesn't follow
by our riddle by my result with God ray
because what this is asking is about
what's happening on a particular flat
surface as you vary directions so you're
only talking about measure 0 sets that
at a given time so this is some kind of
finer result so any questions on this so
I'll wrap this up by some quiet so since
you don't have questions I have some
questions for you so and I think some of
these are kind of absurdities that we
can't answer them or that I don't know
how to answer them and I think they're
great questions so um so notice I was
kicking out a density 0 set of times
even on the flat surfaces I talked about
I don't know what happens off of those
density 0 set of times so pick some kind
of sparse sequence of times so i chose n
factorial but just because it's sparse
no other reason and it has a nice and
you can write it easily could it be that
for almost every point on your flat
surface it converges to itself under the
flow in almost every direction somehow
is unbelievable but I don't know
how to rule this out and I don't know
how to rule out the same statement for
interval exchange transformations so
could it be that for almost every
interval exchange transformation for
some permutation on 80 million intervals
if i look at the IET along n factorial
one-half converges to one-half along the
factorials so that's somehow the
absurdity of our ignorance and so then
the next is kind of a vague question but
I don't think it's studied much and I
think it's a very interesting question
what are the joinings between different
iit's so two typical random I ETS don't
have joinings but can you build pairs of
I ETS that have interesting joinings and
in particular what about an ayiti in
itself what kind of self joinings can it
have so Oaks yeah and so also this
second question about self joinings of
an ayiti is related to a criterion of
each for when an ayiti for a process to
be prime that is has no measurable
factors no simple pieces and that's
another open question about I ETS
whether their prime and then so along
the lines of this full measure set of
flat surfaces but nothing explicit I'm
going to draw you a flat surface the
so-called golden al this side has length
1 this side has length 1 this side has
length root 5 minus 1 over 2 and same
with this side so this is a very special
flat surface it has a large stabilizer
which is actually a lattice it has a lot
of nice structure I think it's unknown
if the flow in two typical pairs of
directions on this are not isomorphic
whether or not there's some secret
isomorphism between two typical
directions so thanks
you